- C'est ici, à l'aile
psychiatrique de la Cité
de la Santé à Laval,
qu'Abdulla Shaikh a été interné
pour la dernière fois, à l'été
2021. Un séjour d'environ
deux semaines marqué par
l'agressivité et les menaces
de l'homme de 26 ans envers
le personnel soignant.
NATHALIE BOURQUE, Syndicat
du CISSS de LAVAL-CSN
- Des menaces de morts,
entre autres. Des menaces, là,
en disant : "Je vais trouver
ton nom... ton nom complet,
ton adresse. Je vais aller
te tuer." C'était " C'était réc.
C'était régulier pendant
son séjour.
- Des membres du personnel
de l'hôpital qui s'occupaient
d'Abdulla Shaikh étaient
terrorisés au point où
un intervenant en santé
mentale a voulu porter plainte
à la police de Laval.
- Il a appelé la police, mais
la police, à l'époque, a dit que
c'était des menaces voilées,
que c'est un patient...
il est en psy.
- Six mois après ce séjour,
la Commission d'examen pour
troubles mentaux a accordé
à Abdullah Shaikh le droit
de séjourner à l'extérieur
d'un établissement de santé.
Selon le rapport consulté par
Radio-Canada, il représentait
toujours un risque élevé
pour la sécurité publique.
Me FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
avocat d'Abdulla Shaikh
- Les personnes peuvent demeurer
en société avec un suivi très
étroit, avec une équipe médicale
compétente, avec... également,
l'équipe médicale est en lien
avec la famille. On s'assure que
la personne prend la médication.
- Il était connu du réseau
de la santé depuis 2018,
après avoir été déclaré
non criminellement responsable
pour cause de troubles mentaux.
Il avait commis le méfait
de brûler son passeport dans
le terminal de l'aéroport
de Montréal.
Depuis 4 ans, il avait séjourné
à l'hôpital en santé mentale
Albert Prévost, puis à
l'institut Philippe-Pinel.
Trois autres séjours
psychiatrie ont été nécessaires
à la Cité de la Santé.
En raison de cette imposante
feuille de route, des conditions
lui avaient été imposées, plaide
son avocat.
- Bien, il y avait la condition
de garder la paix, d'habiter
dans un endroit qui est approuvé
par l'équipe traitante. Il y
avait également des conditions
de prendre la médication.
- La Commission d'examen a
jugé que le risque était
donc acceptable de le suivre à
distance malgré des inquiétudes
exprimés dans son rapport
concernant :
- Je pense que monsieur n'allait
pas bien. Puis, il a passéà tras
quelque part.
- François Legault, lui,
dit avoir parlé de
ses préoccupations avec
son conseil des ministres.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,premier ministc
- Bien là, il faut voir aussi
ce qui est arrivé. Parce
qu'étant donné que c'est
quelqu'un qui était déjà c
pourquoi il a été relâché?
- Reste à savoir également,
comment une personne atteinte
de schizophrénie asisisisisisisi
passé lourd dans le réseau de
la santé a bien pu se procurer
une arme à feu pour commettre
une cava